[Music]
on this Friday night Telecom takeover
approved the mega merger between Shaw
and Rogers the politics the conditions
we'll be watching them like a hawk and
The concerns over competition
tragedy in the St Lawrence River the
Macabre discovery of migrants and the
fears among area residents
Prosecuting a former U.S president what
Donald Trump's indictment might mean for
his other legal problems
plus no longer being brushed off we're
trying very hard to get Beyond a
colonial attitude Canada's expanding
curation of indigenous art
for a Nasser
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin with one of the biggest
corporate takeovers in Canadian history
that's set to reshape telecommunications
in this country the federal government
has granted final approval of rogers's
multi-billion dollar acquisition of
shock Communications the 26 billion
dollar deal received the green light
almost exactly two years to the day
after it was first announced but it
comes with strict stipulations from the
government designed to drive down cell
phone costs and increase access to
low-cost internet critics say that's
still not enough something we'll delve
into in just a moment but first a
breakdown of the deal itself and what it
could mean for millions of Canadians our
senior business correspondent Anne
gaviola begins our coverage tonight
I will ensure that a new fourth National
player can go toe-to-toe with the big
tree and actually drive down prices a
lofty pledge from the industry Minister
as he green lights the 26 billion dollar
Rogers Shaw merger with strings attached
21 conditions to be exact including that
Rogers must establish a western
headquarters in Calgary and create 3 000
jobs in western Canada that will remain
for at least a decade Rogers must invest
five and a half billion dollars to
expand 5G networks the next generation
of wireless and a billion dollars to
connect rural indigenous and remote
communities there are also requirements
that wireless Plans offered by Videotron
be comparable to what's currently
available in Quebec and offer options at
least 20 percent cheaper than the major
competition Financial penalties for not
meeting the conditions are up to 200
million for Videotron up to a billion
for Rogers many wonder how the
conditions can be enforced when there's
no telling who will be running the
country in the coming decade or what the
Telecom landscape may look like the
industry Minister tells Global News the
terms are in writing it is a contract
with the government and it doesn't
matter who's in office perhaps in the
short term there may be a honeymoon
period where we don't see big changes
with respect to pricing but the
suggestion that somehow this this is a
win for consumers I think runs counter
to frankly what most consumers believe
it was basically a done deal from when
they announced it I don't like it less
competition higher prices for the
consumers the deal faced opposition from
the competition Bureau consumer
Advocates and politicians But ultimately
it passed a series of legal and
Regulatory hurdles more consolidation is
likely if Canada's competition laws
aren't changed we should expect to find
ourselves here again with you know maybe
it's a different sector maybe it's
wireless again there will be another
Mega merger the Rogers Shaw deal is
important for fostering confidence in
Canada's ability to get business deals
done according to the CD Howe Institute
a no from Ottawa would have created
economic uncertainty if we're the
company that makes investment country is
going to think twice about what uh what
the law means and how much they can
count on the law to protect your
investment protector protect your plant
Alberta Shaw family controls both Shaw
Communications and chorus entertainment
the parent company of global news and
gaviola Global News Toronto
when Rogers first proposed to acquire
Shaw back in March of 2021 the deal got
a thumbs down from every political party
on Parliament Hill then the companies
involved reworked the pitch and went
back to the Trudeau government the
changes changed the mind of the Liberals
and allowed the deal to proceed but
opposition parties still aren't sold on
the transaction our chief political
correspondent David Aiken has reaction
for us from Ottawa tonight David well
far the government may have changed its
mind on the Takeover of Shah by Rogers
but the opposition remains steadfastly
opposed
[Applause]
suck up to Big oligopolistic
corporations that raise prices on
consumers and make life less affordable
the conservatives slammed the decision
to let Rogers buy Shaw today they
announced that they think that there's
too much competition in the wireless and
in the internet business and they've
allowed for a massive merger and the NDP
were just as harsh this is a disaster
that will end with less competition
the Telco CEOs and are sticking Canadian
families with higher prices and the Bell
but the government believes that a
strong fourth National Wireless player
that would be Freedom mobile under new
owner video Tron will actually lower
prices the Canadians have told us one
thing bring prices down more competition
and the way to do that in Canada is to
have a fourth National player Madam
speaker that's why we impose conditions
because we want lower prices for
Canadians and we'll be watching them
like a hawk the partisan back and forth
aside the massive Telco deal has
highlighted the need for some broader
policy reforms to better regulate
mergers and encourage competition and be
able to do it more efficiently
competition law professor Jennifer Quaid
told the industry committee as much I
actually would make a plea for a bigger
picture approach to maybe think about
how can we build a system that isn't
siled where Regulators can consult each
other and work together and we're not
stepping on each other's toes as for the
Telecom sector all parties on the
commons industry committee already
unanimously recommended structural
changes to the Telecommunications
industry and the industry Minister says
if Rogers and Videotron are not meeting
the government's objectives well that
might be something he will consider if
we don't see meaningful reduction I mean
the house of parliament this morning
I'll be seeking additional power to make
sure that we drive down prices and at
that time everything is on the as
everything is on the table in the
meantime the government has frozen all
transfers of any Telecom licenses giving
itself some time to assess the Fallout
from this Mega deal Farah
David again in Ottawa thank you David
now to the disturbing Discovery and
Recovery mission in the water around
aquasazne Quebec where divers searching
a section of the Saint Lawrence river
found two more bodies following a boat
capsizing yesterday near the U.S border
the bodies of eight people including two
children who both hold Canadian
passports have been pulled from the
river early signs suggest it's the
tragic reality of human smuggling police
say they are still searching for the
30-year-old owner of the small vessel
aquasazane is a mohawk territory and it
lies in the middle of the Saint Lawrence
straddling parts of Quebec Ontario and
New York State prime minister Justin
Trudeau says it's a heartbreaking
situation those who drowned are believed
to be from two migrant families from
India and Romania it's believed they
were trying to cross into the U.S
illegally from Canada Braden Jagger
Haynes reports
what started as an initial search for
one missing person turned into a
horrific Discovery the bodies of
migrants of Indian and Romanian descent
were pulled from The Frigid marshy
Waters of the St Lawrence River near
aquasazny Quebec two canadian-born
children were among the dead police
believe the families were trying to
enter the United States illegally
authorities located the bodies while
searching for a 30 year old Casey Oaks a
local who was reported missing and was
last seen in a small boat Wednesday
night
a vessel matching the description
as being operated by Casey Oaks was also
located near the location of the
deceased persons the territory straddles
Quebec Ontario and New York State and is
known as a Transit point for smuggling
it's always at night they get dropped
off at the shoreline and they're
believing that it's um the USA residents
say illegal activity has increased in
frequency but fear the repercussions if
they speak out quiet about it we don't
say nothing because we might get um
shot or burnt out or you know our house
burnt down as though it's you got to be
quiet since January there have been 48
incidents of people trying to cross
illegally through the territory we're a
very small Police Service
but we're trying our best to increase
the the security and the surveillance of
the community
the federal government is watching the
situation closely this is a
heartbreaking situation obviously there
are many questions that need answered
but we're not going to respond to the
various speculation going on right now
we're going to continue to approach this
with the seriousness and the
thoughtfulness that it requires in the
meantime autopsies are being conducted
along with toxicology tests to determine
the cause of deaths police are
attempting to identify the victims and
determine their status in Canada Brayden
Jagger Haynes Global News aquasosasne
Quebec
to the U.S now where a man who once held
the most powerful office in the world is
days away from having his mug shot and
fingerprints taken former president
Donald Trump was indicted by a grand
jury in New York late Thursday over a
criminal case that centered on hush
Money Paid to an adult film star during
his 2016 campaign now he's expected to
surrender himself to police our Jackson
prosco joins us now with more on the
latest Fallout and of course the
political reaction that comes with this
decision Jackson
well pharah in many places this is seen
as a test of whether or not a former
president is above the law but tonight
Donald Trump is claiming political
persecution and he's trying to rile up
his supporters in his defense
it's a stress test for American
democracy and a stunning fall for a
former president Donald Trump's
arraignment will take place inside this
Manhattan Courthouse next week after he
surrenders and his fingerprinted and
photographed a first for any former or
current president but the same treatment
as any other criminal defendant this is
one of the first times in his life when
he has to play by the rules that
everyone else plays by late Thursday
Trump was informed of the New York Grand
jury's decision to indict him despite
all the scuttlebutt and rumors and
whatnot we believed and hope that rule
of law would have prevailed so he
initially was was shocked reports
suggest he faces 30 or more charges
relating to allegations of business
fraud and a hush money scheme involving
payments to adult film star Stormy
Daniels the specific charges remain
under seal that hasn't stopped the
frenzied claims from Trump's backers I
think the unprecedented indictment of a
former president of the United States
for campaign Finance issue is an outrage
outside Mar-A-Lago Trump's supporters
rallied defiantly actually I think it's
helping him I think he's going to get
more votes now because people maybe will
wake up
but it's in New York where concern
remains about security Trump has
repeatedly called for protests and
warned of violence claiming to be the
target of political persecution in my
case every piece of my personal life
Financial life business life and public
life has been turned upside down and
dissected like no one in the history of
our country what happens next could
Define the 2024 presidential campaign
where Trump is still a candidate
New York could be just the start of
Trump's legal troubles he still faces
multiple probes in far more serious
cases involving election interference
classified documents and the storming of
the U.S Capitol the charges here may
open Pandora's Box in terms of the other
prosecutions that he's facing around the
nation
so Jackson could Trump face prison time
and what do these charges mean for his
presidential campaign
well when it comes to the campaign it's
full steam ahead in fact within minutes
of the indictment being revealed last
night Trump was attempting to fundraise
off his own looming criminal trial as
for the question of jail we won't really
know more about that until the
indictments are unsealed because of
course that will reveal the specific
charges that he's facing it is possible
that some of them could include jail
time if he were convicted but a trial
ultimately is a year or more away and at
the end of the day it's the other court
cases that Trump faces that could pose
far more legal Jeopardy and potentially
jail time for him if he's convicted in
those matters
Jackson prosco in Washington thank you
Jackson
former liberal MP Han dong has served a
libel notice against Global News and our
parent company chorus entertainment the
move follows global news reporting that
two independent National Security
sources said dong had a conversation in
2021 with the Chinese Consul General in
which dong raised the cases of Michael
kovrick and Michael spavor and allegedly
advised China to delay their release
dong denies these allegations a letter
from Dong's lawyer calls the reporting
defamatory he's seeking an apology and a
retraction
membership application approved coming
up how soon Finland could join NATO plus
what the president of Belarus is pushing
for in Ukraine
Finland has overcome its last hurdle to
join NATO nearly a year after seeking
the security of the alliance following
Russia's full-scale invasion of Ukraine
turkey's Parliament officially ratified
finland's bid on Thursday turkey was the
last holdout among 30 member nations
that all must agree on any new member
NATO's Secretary General says Finland
will formally join its military Alliance
in the coming days a similar bid by
Sweden is still in progress but it
stalled over diplomatic grievances with
turkey and Hungary
the president of Belarus is calling for
a ceasefire in Ukraine without
conditions Russia says a ceasefire would
not achieve the goals of its so-called
special military operation in its annual
address Alexander lukashenka also called
for Moscow and Kiev to start talks on a
peace deal Russia says Ukraine needs to
accept losing territory Ukraine says
Russia must withdraw its troops as a
precursor to any agreement lukashenka
also offended the storage of Russian
tactical nuclear weapons in his country
and says Russia could place powerful
strategic nuclear weapons there too he
says they're needed to protect
sovereignty through any means necessary
[Music]
I had the struggle to meet mental health
needs in Nova Scotia after the worst
mass shooting in Canadian history
[Music]
one of the most powerful messages from
Nova scotia's mass casualty commission
is a warning about mental health the
final report into Canada's worst mass
shooting was released on Thursday the
Commissioners say even three years later
there is a public health emergency Mike
Armstrong explains
Community still reeling from what it
went through there was the loss 22
people friends and family were deeply
affected and then there are people like
Janet Ackerman who followed the news and
hid in her home she lives just a few
kilometers from where the whole thing
started the gunman's home was on this
property while he was on the loose
Ackerman hid that was locked up and in
my bedroom and I just stayed there so
that's what I did the whole day the
whole day it was in a way a trauma on
top of a trauma the mass shooting took
place in the first weeks of the pandemic
across the country psychologists were
already busy
the mass casualty commission's final
report says the mental health needs of
the community's most affected were never
met there is still to this day it says a
public health emergency families are not
receiving the mental health support that
they need local MP says after the
tragedy governments never stepped up he
says people have been paying for mental
health services out of their own Pockets
that there's been no compensation that
is something the commission says should
be addressed it calls for the
governments of Canada and Nova Scotia to
quote jointly fund a program to address
the public health emergency in the local
communities and that it should be done
soon by May 1st of this year
both the Prime Minister and the premier
were at the report's release neither
committed to anything saying they need
time to study it three thousand Pages uh
for sure there's there's a lot the
report also says there is a mental
health problem for First Responders it's
as many are still affected by what they
live through and getting help to them
isn't easy they in fact tend to downplay
their need for support
Mike Armstrong Global News portapick
Nova Scotia
[Music]
curating indigenous art next in
vesting indigenous peoples have created
some of the most recognizable and prized
pieces of Art in Canada but for
Generations they haven't always been
part of the decision-making process
about how art is selected and presented
in Galleries and museums and that's
starting to change this week on the new
reality Donna Friesen looks at how
indigenous voices are now leading the
conversation about art in this country
the National Gallery in Ottawa is home
to the largest collection of art created
in Canada and yet it might surprise you
the gallery only added its first piece
of contemporary indigenous art in the
mid-1980s an indication perhaps of how
much the art World viewed the
significance of indigenous Works
institutions don't change themselves
people change institutions over the last
year the gallery has been rethinking its
approach launching the department of
indigenous ways and decolonization for
the first time in this institution's
80-year history you have not won but two
indigenous people at the highest level
of decision making at our executive
management level so when you start
bringing in those lived perspectives
that starts to change things from the
inside this is a beautiful piece that
means embedding indigenous voices and
expertise in all aspects of the National
Gallery
indigenous art history of this land
there's indigenous art histories from
other lands we're starting to understand
the plurality of cultural expression and
getting away from this notion of the
dominance of one kind but the new
Department hasn't come without
opposition faced with the reality that
change can be threatening and not
everyone is open to it you're always
going to get that pushback because this
is about power and privilege and
institutions like this are built on
Power and privilege but that can't deter
us from what we're doing the Winnipeg
Art Gallery has taken a new approach
launching a one of its kind Center for
Inuit art and culture this is kamayuk
it's in the heart of Winnipeg not in
Inuit territory but everything about it
was designed in consultation with Inuit
knowledge Keepers and Elders it's
designed to be a bridge between the
North and the South we're trying very
hard to get Beyond a colonial attitude
towards art just opening up being
transparent bringing people into the
process not just saying well this is the
way we do it and that's that's that
kamego is so important on so many levels
Glenn gear a multi-disciplinary artist
of mixed Inuit background was
commissioned to create an installation
for kamayuk's opening in 2021
having the the gallery featuring Inuit
work from across the union and got and
showing that diversity of voices is
something that has a longevity it's
something that I feel really connected
to kamayuk is the largest public
collection of contemporary Inuit art in
the world showcasing pieces spanning
Generations while fostering
relationships with artists and their
communities 30 years ago we didn't have
the the language to really think about
what decolonizing a space would mean and
I think now there's a lot more dialogue
with indigenous non-indigenous folks
that challenge sort of those those
hierarchies institutions like this can
be gathering places and for the past and
the present and the future
intersect and I think that's what art
and culture does and can do and must do
and we have to be the facilitators of
that kind of change claiming a rightful
place in the present and creating
inclusive Equitable galleries for the
future Donna Friesen Global News
and for an inside look at that largest
public collection of Inuit art and to
learn more about the state of the system
of Art in Canada watch the new reality
right here on global Saturday at 7 pm
and that's global national for this
Friday night I'm Farah Nasser and your
Canada tonight is Kamloops British
Columbia until tomorrow take care of
yourselves and take care of each other
good night
[Music]